[Music]
systems research is the foundation
innovation grows from it is a science
where technology expands the
state-of-the-art and computing
infrastructure and that's what will be
explored and discussed August 1st and
2nd at the Microsoft Research faculty
summit 2018 systems fuelling future
disruptions at the research faculty
summit system's discussion will include
the intelligent edge for IOT in the
cloud converge for low latency
applications and breakthrough
innovations like DNA glass and how
underwater data centers are being used
for long term and low cost cloud storage
you'll hear how researchers are
envisioning self-tuning AI systems and
not just quantum computers but quantum
systems plus you'll learn more about the
expiration of confidential computing and
trends and blockchain technologies it's
the future reveal B particle go to wwm
Ike receive a collusive accom to
register for keynotes live streamed on
August 1st and 2nd